I'm Laura Ingram and this is the Ingram
angle from Washington tonight Americans
recoil as Dems sell perversion that's
the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
trans youth are vulnerable you really
want to to to debase our treatment and
uh and to affirm and to uh support and
Empower these youth not to limit their
participation and activities and sports
and even limit their ability to get
gender affirmation treatment in their
state no it's not Halloween it's the
Biden administration's version of normal
as inflation continues to tear through
household budgets and weaken America
they Trot out Rachel Levine from HHS to
promote dangerous hormone blockers and
life-altering trans surgery for minors
this is sick
adults preying on our children under the
guise of providing Health Care claiming
that anyone who criticizes their tactics
and their goals is bigoted or intolerant
and they're Twisted forces that are
backing them yeah they're well funded
and they're Fanning out Across America
in New York the home of sexual deviance
drag Story Hour dsh NYC it's a
taxpayer-funded non-profit puts on shows
for children as young as three and one
of its more prominent performers has
social media accounts filled with nudity
and other sexually explicit content
Oliver her face who also goes by Angel
is aguer is one of the talents listed on
the dsh website the organization
sanitized bio of her face describes him
as a drag king and a former daycare
teacher who has a passion for working
with children especially what it means
to be queer and trans the education of
that but one video posted on his social
media profile shows her face pretending
to stab his breasts while wearing a
chest binder
okay but don't worry he warns his
followers to not bind longer than six to
eight hours and urges them to be safe
of course Lefty lawmakers they defend
this garbage claiming that this drag
queen group dsh is an opportunity for
children as young as three to engage in
play of gender fluidity in childhood it
also helps them learn about love in a
safe space
and just down I-95 in Harrisburg
Pennsylvania a pride event last week
included drag queens encouraging kids to
pole dance
even allowing them to take a twirl
here's the woman behind posting and
defending it
whole Fitness is appropriate for all
ages could you imagine asking a social
worker if it was appropriate for a child
to do Pole Fitness when every playground
in this country has a fireman's pull on
it
you probably get laughed at
yeah While most were rightly horrified
by this not Pennsylvania's Democrat
Governor Tom Wolf in fact he sent a
letter that said how honored he was to
support the event remember he's one who
gave us Rachel Levine and across the
country in Washington state we found
perhaps the most maddening story of the
week an 80 year old grandmother was
banned there from her YMCA after
demanding that a biological male leave
the woman's locker room where little
girls were undressing
addressing the Port Townsend city
council last Monday here's how Julie
jayman who's the band senior citizen
described what happened
in an effort by the city and the YMCA to
apply the neocultural gender rules at
Mountain View pool dressing shower room
facilities women and children are being
put at risk
my experience while showering after my
swim was hearing a man's voice in the
women's dressing area and seeing a man
in a women's swimsuit watching little
girls pull down their bathing suits in
order to use the toilets in the dressing
room
I reacted by telling him to leave and
the consequence is that I have been
banned from the pool the Y has not
provided any dressing shower room
options for women who do not want to be
exposed to men who identify as women
it is unconscionable that the YMCA would
instigate these new policies without
clearly informing pool patrons and
parents
okay first of all that Granny rocks but
when pressed Port Townsend Washington
police said that Mr Mrs Jamon had an
emotional response to a strange male
being in the bathroom and helping a
young girl take off her bathing suit
well I should hope the response to that
would be emotional
so so much for liberals by the way
wanting women's feelings like Mrs
jaman's feelings respected I only I
guess only certain type of women what
certain liberal women they get respect
and once again the left is encouraging
this Insanity Biden's expansion of the
categories of people protected under
Title IX requires now that men who
identify as women be allowed full access
to the women and girls restrooms the
locker rooms including locker rooms of
K-12 facilities and other higher ed
facilities
so what does that mean for the 80 year
old grandmother you just saw who was
obviously in good faith acting in the
best interest of that little girl
well at best she's going to be persona
non grata among the elites at worst
should probably be sued civilly and
could even be subject to a federal civil
rights investigation
I don't put anything past Merrick
Garland these days
but looking at all this
what's amazing though is that Democrats
actually think this plays Beyond the
coast that this helps them electorally
just because I know their leaders are
happy to promote this freakish dangerous
Behavior it certainly doesn't mean the
rest of the voters are and smart
Governors like Ron DeSantis in Florida
they're fighting back at every turn
for our kids their innocence and the
Traditions that made America great
and that's the angle
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else